[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo je suis
ravi de vous accueillir ici au parlement
européen à strasbourg
pour cette nouvelle demi heure
d'actualité européenne à la une de cette
édition cet accord sur le brésil trouvé
entre les négociateurs britanniques et
européens
une étape décisive dans ces négociations
qui n'en finissait plus de buter sur un
point celui de la frontière néerlandaise
nous en discuterons tout au long de
cette émission avec nos invités nous
partirons aussi au portugal qui affiche
depuis quelques mois de très bons
indicateurs économiques
une embellie qui embarrasse bruxelles
car depuis bientôt trois ans le
gouvernement de gauche d'antonio costa
applique une politique anti austérité
mais nous le verrons dans notre
reportage ses résultats reste à pondérer
car certains chiffres masquent une
réalité plus contrastée mais d'abord
revenons sur le break citer cet accord
technique trouvé entre les britanniques
et les européens un texte obtenue au
prix d'âpres négociations
écoutez sa réaction alors enfin il ya un
accord mais on sait qu'on doit
maintenant voir si ça va passer de au
parlement britannique est aussi un
conseil ici et je sais que chez moi
c'est c'est vraiment difficile de ces
patients du tout l'équipe européenne
était prêt sous la houlette de michel
barnier ont travaillé très dur très bien
en veillant à l'intérêt de l'union
européenne et les britanniques il
fallait éviter le piège que les
britanniques ne sortent mais guère des
avantages du marché intérieur ça c'était
inacceptable évidemment donc c'était
évidemment compliqué la question
irlandaise
était pas le moins épineux des problèmes
et donc je pense qu'il ya encore des
étapes à franchir
je me réjouis qui est une avancée est
quand même dans les négociations car
mais tout n'est pas bouclé et pour en
discuter j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
sur ce plateau jean arthuis bonjour
bonjour vous êtes français membres de
l'udps et y est vous appartenait au
groupe des démocrates et libéraux dans
ce parlement européen à vos côtés
aujourd'hui charles tannock bonjour
bonjour alex vous êtes britannique est
membre du parti conservateur alors la
première question pour vous jean arthuis
le référendum sur le breakbeat c'était
il ya plus de deux ans on arrive enfin à
un accord technique
c'est un soulagement j'imagine pour les
européens oui c'est un soulagement
maintenant c'est un accord provisoire
dans l'attenté d'un accord plus plus
structurelle mais ça reste un
soulagement on va prendre du temps pour
trouver des termes plus précis et mais
peut-être que c'est un accord qui durera
il s'agit d'étendre ce qu'on avait
imaginé pour régler le problème de la
frontière entre l'irlande du nord et
l'irlande d'étendre cette union
douanière
une mesure très très exceptionnel de
l'étendre à l'ensemble du royaume uni
donc c'est un pas significatif dans ces
négociations dont on attendait enfin
dont on était plus sûr finalement quelle
qu'elles aboutissent
je rappelle quand même que la commission
européenne en début de semaine
présentait encore son plan d'action en
cas de nos deals et bien c'est un accord
comme un démon collègues pas provisoire
parce qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de temps
pour nicole et négociations maintenant
et il nous reste que quatre mois en fait
à mon avis c'est le meilleur possible
dans les conditions politiques et les
limites des déclarations faites par le
gouvernement britannique
alors c'est un modèle qui se rapproche
un peu au modèle de jazz et dans les
îles anglo normandes
alors justement on le sait le principal
point d'achoppement dans ces
négociations
c'est la question de la frontière
irlandaise revenons un peu en arrière en
décembre 2017 lorsque theresa may
s'engagent à éviter le retour d'une
frontière entre l'irlande du nord
territoire britannique et la république
d'irlande membres de l'union européenne
un engagement pris pour préserver les
accords de 1998 qui avaient mis fin à 30
ans de guerre civile en irlande
les européens avaient alors proposé que
l'irlande du nord reste dans l'union
douanière européenne une solution
écartée par les britanniques qui
préférait voir l'ensemble du royaume uni
demeurer dans l'union douanière de
manière temporaire
une option rejetée à son tour par les
européens quel compromis 'achat' à
'neutre'
on était là le problème ça sera dans la
question du deal pixels à parti
protestant qui donne son appui au
gouvernement britannique pour rester au
pouvoir
à mon avis ils ont dit hier que comme il
y aura encore des contrôles sur des
règlements européens des petites
contrôle que à mon avis ils ne veulent
pas appuyer l'accord s'ils voteront
contre
ça sera vraiment grands risques
programmes aux britanniques
et si là et s'ils ne sont plus d'accord
avec lui qu'elle reste au pouvoir que le
gouvernement minoritaire est au pouvoir
ça sent encore un autre problème plus
grand pour madame mais alors c'est
vraiment à ces critiques les prochaines
semaines on sera miens bien renseigné
parce qu'il faut lire le document mais
il n'ya aucun doute qu'à mon avis de
rester comme clan membres de l'union
européen c'est beaucoup plus c'est
beaucoup supérieur mieux qu'avant
l'accord de ses gendres à il ya la
possibilité d'un d'une deuxième
possibilité c'est possible en deuxième
référendum ça j'ai la sphère des
britanniques
bien sûr de faire des députés européens
la solution trouvée est ce qu'elle est
bonne pour les conseils qu'ils proposent
est là est une solution pragmatique pas
mater ou une pragmatique mais le diable
sera dans les détails parce que la
grande bretagne va rester dans le
royaume uni va rester dans l'union
douanière marché intérieur donc ça veut
dire que des droits de douane seront
perçus en grande bretagne les reversé au
budget de l'union européenne
ça veut dire qu'on va également demandé
à la grande bretagne de ne pas faire
marche arrière
r s'agissant de normes sociales de
normes environnementales qui sont
aujourd'hui en vigueur en europe
mais c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus
beaucoup pire que rester comprend
membres de l'union parce que là on aura
plus aucun méthodes de législation et
alors on va recevoir les lois européens
mais sans aucune possibilité de les
influencer ou de l'échangé et ça pour
moi c'est encore pire et ça c'est
intéressant que les airs aux critiques
et les propre et un beau coup de sang
contre cet accord parce que c'est un
compromis qui ne plaît pas à tout le
monde parce que c'est un compromis a
lancé siné zinini c'est l'indépendance
totale avec notre possibilité d'avoir
notre politique de commerce extérieur
parce qu'on reste dans le union
douanière et on n'est pas aussi ici pour
enfoncer les droits et faire les droits
qu'on avec notre notre partenaire
européen l'an à mon avis elle aura des
problèmes dans le parlement national de
la choisille de choisi le moindre mal
mais tout ceci ne peut être que
provisoire
peut-être est-ce le prélude au retour de
la grande bretagne dans les eaux
européennes
moi je serais pour ça bien sûr mais
c'est il est à la petite possibilité
dans le cas que cette si cet accord
n'est pas à voter dans la chambre des
communes qu'il y aura une deuxième
référendum et là la bataille sera de une
référendum avec l'option de rester
complaints membres merci beaucoup à tous
les deux d'avoir été nos invités
aujourd'hui je vous propose maintenant
de revenir en images sur plus de deux
ans de négociations sur le breakbeat du
référendum du 23 juin 2016 à l'accord
technique qui vient d'être conclue
d'âpres discussions entre le royaume uni
et les vingt-sept dont nous vous
rappelons les étapes clés
[Musique]
23 janvier 2013 david cameron premier
ministre promet aux anglais de les
consulter sur le maintien de la
grande-bretagne dans l'union on est
toujours là il ne mesure pas encore le
séisme qu'il va déclencher
s'il remporte les élections législatives
sur cette promesse et malgré sa campagne
contre le break site le weed emporte
avec 51 89% et des suffrages des
missionnaires david cameron est remplacé
par el la conservatrice theresa may une
eurosceptique convaincu et partisane
d'un bric si dur
lorsqu'elle annonce vouloir sortir du
marché unique 29 mars 2010 est le
premier ministre britannique est écrit
au président du conseil européen et
déclenché la procédure prévue par
l'article 50 du traité de lisbonne des
stocks en dés s'ouvre alors une période
de négociation sans machine arrière
possible
quel sera le montant de l'enveloppé
financière à régler par la grande
bretagne pour honorer ses engagements
européens déjà contractés quid du sort
des ressortissants européens déjà vivant
sur le sol britannique
quelle relation et accords commerciaux
et douaniers subsisteront avec l'union
déjà complexe l'équation va encore un
peu plus ce compliqué theresa may
fragilisé s'appuie désormais sur le
parti unioniste irlandais le déut paix
pour remporter des législatives
anticipées
un allié encombrant qui veut rester
coûte que coûte arrimé à la grande
bretagne au risque de rétablir une
frontière physique entre l'irlande du
nord territoire britannique et l'irlande
du sud membres de l'union européenne
malmenée par sa coalition entre les
tenants d'un bric site durée des
partisans d'une sortie négociée
theresa may se fait régulièrement
chahuté à la chambre des communes
jusqu'à l'éclatement de son gouvernement
et de départ en juillet 2
18 de son tonitruant ministre des
affaires étrangères boris johnson
septembre 2018 theresa may pense avoir
trouvé la solution à l'équation
irlandaise pierre d'achoppement de la
signature d'un accord avant d'être
sèchement contredite au sommet de
salzbourg par les 27 chefs d'états
européens alors que la perspective d'un
no deal se profilait l'accord technique
survenu mardi 12 novembre apparaît comme
une possibilité fragile de sortie de
crise
et pour continuer à parler de cet accord
sur le brésil m'a rejoint sur ce plateau
ana gomes bonjour vous êtes portugaise
membres du parti socialiste est dans ce
parlement européen vous faites partie du
groupe des socialistes et démocrates à
vos côtés aujourd'hui philippe lambert
bonjour je vous êtes belge membre du
parti écolo en belgique et coprésident
du groupe des verts dans ce parlement
européen et pour compléter ce plateau
j'ai le plaisir de recevoir godelieve
quiz tout de revol bonjour oui bonjour
vous êtes allemande membres de la cd ou
et du parti populaire européen
oui philippe lambert dont on a beaucoup
parlé un ces derniers mois du risque
d'un odile sur certains secteurs de
l'économie notamment cet accord
technique c'est donc plutôt rassurants
selon vous mais pour l'instant il n'y a
pas là car rien de garanti évidemment
que cet accord à ce la rampe à la
chambre des communes qui landes est très
divisé et le risque que la chambre des
communes rejette l'accord est loin
d'être négligeable autrement dit le
risque d'une ode il demeure et donc
j'appelle en tout cas chacune et chacun
à décider en son âme et conscience et
surtout en ayant l'intérêt général à
l'esprit parce qu'un une sortie du
royaume uni sans accord serait
extrêmement dommageable bien sûr pour le
royaume uni mais aussi pour tous les
états riverains du royaume uni à
commencer par l'irlande mais bien sûr
tous les états qui frères la mer du nord
donc il reste encore beaucoup d'étapes à
franchir selon vous oui je les mêmes
opinions que le collègue et que le
collègue des verts je crois que c'est
surtout aux britanniques même maintenant
de faire les par l'union européenne a
fait ce qu'elle pouvait on a fait des
propositions valables
ici je j'ai l'impression qu'au sein du
parlement européen
tout le monde partage plus ou moins la
même opinion avec des détails différents
mais cette passe est important de se
débrouiller à londres qu'il faut qu'on
travaille
et là moi je vois pas que ça fait aussi
parce que les animosités personnelles
c'est pas objectif tout ça et ce n'est
pas neutre en ce sens qu'on ne regarde
pas ce que les traités est bien ou pas
est-ce que l'accord est valable mais on
regardait ce qu'on aime theresa may
est-ce qu'il faut autre chose
est ce qu'on peut faire la révolution
interne
à la chambre sauf commande et vous anna
gomis vous êtes optimiste sur l'issue je
suis du même avis il faut voir aussi que
nous au parlement européen on doit aussi
ratifié cet accord s'il est en fait
accepté par la chambre des communes et
donc on a toutes ces questions mais je
pense qu'au parlement européen où on
devra le faire si on suit l'accord en
fait respecte nos lignes rouges et les
droits des citoyens nos citoyens et les
citoyens britanniques chez nous sont d
une question primordiale
moi en tant que socialiste portugaise
j'aimerais que les forces notamment du
lait bas demande en deuxième référendum
et vous pensez que c'est possible une
possibilité je pense que c'est possible
tout est possible
c'est beaucoup plus possible aujourd'hui
ça semble plus possible au gic le
simplet il ya une année c'est quelque
chose que je souhaitais aussi philippe
lambertz un deuxième référendum
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que le
royaume uni reste au sein de l'union
européenne et donc si les forces
démocratiques au royaume-uni parviennent
à faire accoucher une pareille décision
c'est à dire soit que ne pas sortir soit
sur sortir formellement mais en période
de transition décidé finalement de
revenir je m'en réjouirai maintenant il
nous appartient pas à
à décider comment le royaume uni doit
doit gérer la chose je pense que une
intervention de responsables politiques
des vingt-sept dans le débat interne au
royaume uni sera en fait
contre-productif
très bien alors je vous propose pour la
deuxième partie de ce débat de changer
de sujet et de prendre la direction du
portugal pays qui fait figure
d'exception dans l'union européenne avec
ses mesures anti austérité après trois
ans de coupes budgétaires imposées par
le précédent gouvernement
les socialistes au pouvoir depuis 2000
15 soutenu par une union des gauches
applique une politique de relance par la
demande des mesures qu'ils prennent
bruxelles à contre-pied et cela semble
marcher avec de bons résultats
économiques mais attention certains
indicateurs sont à analyser avec mesures
car il cache une réalité plus sombre
voyez ce reportage de sandra cerqueira
[Musique]
les ruelles pittoresques qui bouge et se
transforme lisbonne s'offre un coup de
jeune le centre historique est envahie
par les grues et les immeubles en ruine
font place à des hôtels il s'en ouvre
une dizaine de nouveaux chaque année ça
c'est un immeuble qui qui a été récupéré
par nous entre 2011 et 2013
quand on lâche t il était complètement
délabré cet investisseur français a
racheté ce bâtiment une bouchée de pain
500 euros le mètre carré
aujourd'hui les 12 chambres de cet hôtel
sont réservées de mars à novembre
il dit même avoir du mal à recruter du
personnel j'ai l'impression que le
portugal du point de vue touristique a
profité de la crise donc ce qui a fait
qu'à partir du parti à ce moment là pas
mal d'emplois se sont créés dans
l'hôtellerie jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant
et c'est pas fini et c'est pas fini
là par exemple en ce moment on parle
d'un nouvel aéroport un nouvel aéroport
qui devrait voir le jour dans deux ans
parce que l'aéroport actuel ne peut pas
dire tout moment
[Musique]
après plusieurs années de crise le boom
du tourisme a contribué à l'embellie
économique du pays la croissance ne
faiblit pas 2,3 pour cent cette année et
le taux de chômage est passé de 17 à -2
9% d'une renaissance que le pays
attendait depuis longtemps
[Musique]
à 30 kilomètres de lisbonne cette
entreprise de pièces détachées notamment
pour l'industrie automobile voit ses
exportations sans cesse augmenté c'est
ce modèle qui va être exporté en
roumanie
le dirigeant ne s'attendait pas à une
telle reprise qu'il a même dû recruter
une dizaine de salariés
ils sont aujourd'hui une quarantaine en
cdi à travailler à temps plein nous
n'avions plus aucun investissement au
portugal plus aucun client nationale
nous avions perdu tous nos contrats et
avons évité de peu les licenciements
aujourd'hui l'industrie nationale a
retrouvé une certaine stabilité
notre entreprise se porte mieux qu'avant
la crise est une actrice
selon lui rien n'aurait été possible
sans les mesures prises par le
gouvernement de gauche portugais et l'ue
en 2015 alors que l'europe entière se
serre la ceinture
depuis trois ans le portugal mène une
politique de relance plus loin de
l'austérité imposée par bruxelles
avec une augmentation du salaire minimum
à près de 600 euros en échange d'une
baisse de cotisations pour les
employeurs il est clair que cette
politique de relance du gouvernement a
contribué à stimuler l'économie
ça a été une aide réelle l'augmentation
du pouvoir d'achat et donc la
consommation dans le pays qu'on permette
de rétablir mais si le portugal réalise
de belles performances sur le plan
économique et prévoit de ramener son
déficit à 0,4 pour cent du pib
une ombre au tableau perdure celle de la
dette publique
autre problème la baisse du taux de
chômage qui pour cet économiste cache
une réalité plus sombre
le marché du travail reste précaire
bon nombre d'emplois créés depuis trois
ans dans le secteur du tourisme
notamment sont des contrats courts peu
qualifiés et mal rémunérés sur le marché
du travail portugais on compte 22 % de
cdd c'est l'un des plus hauts niveaux
d'europe et malgré la baisse du chômage
il est toujours aussi difficile pour les
jeunes diplômés de trouver un emploi
plus jeu
tout le travail
cet infirmier a enchaîné les contrats
courts pendant plusieurs années avant
d'être titularisé son souhait que le
retour aux 35 heures attribuées aux
fonctionnaires soient généralisés il a
le sentiment que le redressement
économique ne profite pas encore à tous
le gouvernement a délaissé les
infirmiers cela fait un an que nous
attendons la revalorisation de notre
statut et de nos salaires le
gouvernement s'était engagé à le faire
quand la situation économique sera
meilleur c'est le cas aujourd'hui et
après plusieurs jours de grève rien ne
change mobilisés depuis des semaines
ils réclament plus de moyens pour
l'hôpital public progrès tant que le
gouvernement mise davantage sur
l'investissement privé l'hôpital je
travaille en périphérie de lisbonne se
trouve dans un état de vétusté tels que
nous n'avons plus de conditions de
travail satisfaisantes travaux ont
commencé il ya trois ans et aujourd'hui
ils sont à l'arrêt faute
d'investissements publics d'un reprise
économique est là mais dans le secteur
public nous n'en tirons pas vraiment les
bénéfices dans son entourage certains de
ses collègues infirmiers sont sur le
point de quitter le pays car même s'il a
diminué avec la reprise
l'exode des jeunes diplômés portugais
continue
[Musique]
alors première question pour vous ana
gomes vous appartenez au même parti que
le premier ministre portugais antonio
costa le portugal inquiète a confirmé sa
réputation de bon élève de la zone euro
en présentant son projet de budget à la
commission européenne le pays vise un
déficit à 0 1% c'est quoi le secret
alors le secret c'est de ce libre libéré
de cette recette qui était complètement
erronée de l'austérité et je ne dis pas
la rigueur fiscale et la différence qui
a été fait avec ce gouvernement
socialiste avec le soutien parlementaire
à la gauche
c'était cet engagement de retourner des
revenus aux familles comme ça de pousser
à la consommation intérieure donc aussi
aider aux exportations de se développer
et en même temps avec la rigueur de la
gestion des comptes publics qui nous a
permis cette trajectoire donc de
équilibre fiscal de manière beaucoup
plus clair que jamais mais le côté plus
sombre
on l'a vu dans ce reportage c'est le
manque d'investissements publics
philippe lamberti bien sûr bien sûr il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de miracle bon
c'est clair que les finances publiques
du portugal avait besoin d'être
restaurée je pense en effet quelle
recette qui ont été adoptées au portugal
sont
je veux dire plus conforme à la science
économique autrement dit on voudrait
nous faire croire que les politiques
visant à comprimer les salaires a
compris mais sans fin des dépenses
publiques pour permettre en fait aux
détenteurs de capitaux de s'enrichir
sous prétexte que les détenteurs de
capitaux sont ceux qui font fonctionner
l'économie mais en fait ces recettes là
ne sont pas fondées dans la réalité
elles sont fondées sur une fausse
science
la théorie économique théo classique qui
n'a aucun fondement réel
je pense qu'il est bien que le
gouvernement portugais s'en soit il
année ceci dit si vous voulez à à une
société à haut niveau de vie vous devez
faire la course à la valeur ajoutée en
tête et je pense que nous européens
devons être extrêmement attentif à cela
parce que il ne faut pas croire que le
reste du monde va se contenter d'être
notre usine d'assemblage je veux dire la
fille monte dans la chaîne de valeur est
dit est extraordinaire si nous ne sommes
pas capables de faire la course en tête
dans les activités à très forte valeur
ajoutée et bien alors nous aurons un
problème et je pense que c'est un
processus
on peut pas demander au portugal ou à
n'importe quel état européen de
transformer son économie en un
claquement de doigt ce n'est pas
possible mais en tout cas c'est
clairement l'accent doit doit se trouver
la priorité alors il ya aussi un autre
indicateur sur lequel il faut avoir une
double lecture ainsi la baisse du
chômage se doit de livres christophe
revel
je crois que la première chose à faire
c'est vraiment d'essayer d'avoir autant
un chômage qui est aussi bas que
possible même si les contrats ne sont
pas toujours magnifique je crois qu'il
vaut mieux travailler si on n'est pas
capable de vivre de son travail
on peut ajouter de l'aide de l'état mais
d'abord intégrer autant que possible
surtout les jeunes dans le monde du
travail et ça d'une façon positive parce
qu'on a une tout autre opinion de soi
même si on est capable de réaliser
quelque chose absolument première
priorité
en un sens bon évidemment en tant
qu'allemand tracé d où la politique
d'austérité
on connaît mais je crois que les
économies
en europe seront toujours très
différentes en allemagne on est plus ou
moins d'accord on a été plus ou moins
d'accord avec la politique d'austérité
maintenant il ya un certain changement
de mentalité qui se fait mais ça vaut
pour l'allemagne pourquoi pas en fait
d'un autre côté il faudrait maintenant
des investissements publics et on va s'y
mettre
ce n'est peut-être pas valable pour
toutes les économies quand je voudrais
justement qu'on revienne sur le cas
italien le gouvernement a annoncé qu'il
maintenait son projet de budget malgré
le rejet par la commission européenne un
budget jugé hors des clous par le
commissaire aux affaires économiques
contrairement aux années passées
la commission n'a malheureusement pas pu
considérer le projet de budget italien
conforme à la recommandation du conseil
adoptée unanimement en juillet dernier
je pense non je ne pense pas je suis
certain que la commission loi d'être un
frein pour l'italie agisse comme un des
moteurs de l'investissement en italie et
c'est un allié pour la croissance de ce
pays alors en 2016 dans le portugal
risquaient aussi une amende mais c'est
une procédure qui a été abandonnée au
bout d'un an mais parce que justement le
trajet fait par le gouvernement
socialiste a permis à la commission de
libérer le portugal de ce procédure de
déficit excessif et ça a eu des
retombées énormes parce que ça fait
baisser les
ce qu'on paye des intérêts par notre
dette publique qui est toujours très
élevé mais quand même elle se réduit
clairement et ça a diminué donc le poids
des dépenses par rapport à la dette
publique parce qu'aussi les agences de
rating tard elles mais elles ont aussi
remis le portugal au même niveau qu'elle
était avant la crise et ça été positif
mais je dois dire que je suis d'accord
avec mes collègues l'investissement
c'est une question public c'est une
question essentielle directrice et ça ne
dépend pas seulement du portugal
ça dépend beaucoup de l'europe si on a
une politique qui notamment au niveau de
l'allemagne
aussi aide à la convergence au sein de
la monnaie unique de l'hérault et donc
qui encourage l'investissement public
et puis on a un grand problème et il
faut dire une des conséquences de cette
austérité de la traite pas seulement au
portugal mais dans les pays qui ont
souffert le studio c'est qu'on a vendu
très bon marché des secteurs critiques
de notre de nos enfants structure de
notre économie
et pas seulement pour le portugal pour
l'union européenne il faut savoir que
par exemple la le aujourd'hui c'est le
parti communiste chinois à travers ces
compagnies d'état qui contrôle le
produit de la production et la
distribution de l'énergie électrique au
portugal c'est quand même grave pour
l'union européenne
vous êtes d'accord c'est une
responsabilité très lourde comporte ceux
qui ont défendu lost arrêté au niveau
européen
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec notre
collègue louis en 2018
mais au moment où on a fait qu on a
privatisé tout ça la situation était une
situation différente et on n'a pas pu
voir ont tellement loin dans l'avenir
mais si on regarde maintenant par
exemple l'italie les plans de l'italie
de privatiser le porte jeunes avec
l'argent chinois d'inviter des
investisseurs chinois maintenant en 2018
alors là je crois que au vu de la de
l'économie globale qu'il faut faire très
attention
maintenant il ya toujours moyen de
retourner ce qu'on a fait dans le passé
en grèce par exemple on a voulu
privatiser le port d'athènes moi je
trouve que en principe un port privé est
une bonne chose
en principe et je me rappelle que
d'entendre dans la grande crise grecque
on a essayé de trouver des investisseurs
en allemagne et les allemands ont dit
non c'est trop risqué alors ce sont les
chinois qui sont venus est bien là
c'était une faute
pourquoi ne pas faire ça au niveau
européen peut pas prendre le risque et y
avoir assez de confiance
oui dans notre système européen dans ce
que nous disons beaucoup austérité ou
pas austérité était une forme de
dogmatisme du marché qui est à l'oeuvre
en europe depuis 30 ans évidemment qui a
été accélérée à l'occasion de la crise
cette idée que si vous privatiser ça
sera mieux géré si vous privatiser ce
sera moins cher si vous préviens tease
et ce sera plus efficace que
constate-t-on on a privatisé au royaume
uni et le chemin de fer et une bonne
partie des services publics on l'a fait
un peu partout en europe que constatons
c'est que ça coûte plus cher à l'état
c'est moins bien géré tout parce que
tout simplement la logique de ce qu'on
appelle bien improprement les
investisseurs jeudi les détenteurs de
capitaux est l'extraction de la rentrer
ce n'est pas créer de la valeur pour la
société sait extraire de la société une
rente et vous payez donc cette rente
comme usagers que vous ne payez pas
autrefois lorsque vous payez par vos
impôts les services publics et donc ce
dogmatisme de marché il faut en sortir
et il est inscrit dans nos règles
budgétaires puisque en fait on pénalise
l'investissement public parce qu'on
demain en tenez vous bien à ce que les
pouvoirs publics lorsqu'ils investissent
comptabilise latéralité de
l'investissement l'année où
l'investissement est fait c'est comme si
dans mon entreprise
vous créez une nouvelle aciérie et on
vous demande en fait de ne pas vous
endetter pour faire une aciérie qui
m'appelait durer 30 40 ou 50 ans ça n'a
évidemment pas de sens c'est à dire
qu'on écrit dans les règles budgétaires
des choses qui n'ont pas de sens pour en
fait donné l'impression qu'il est
impossible que l'état investisse merci
beaucoup c'est ainsi que se termine
notre débat aujourd'hui merci à tous les
trois d'y avoir participé merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis et vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
nos différents sites lcpan public sénat
et rtbf.be très belle semaine à tous et
à très bientôt
[Musique]